so you're mainly known for the voice of
Bugs Bunny at care
[Music]
ERS brought to you by yeah
[Music]
my childhood
[Music]
all right everybody welcome back to
another awesome episode of the careful
boys and today we have a very special
guest he is a I got pulled up and [ __ ]
five-time Emmy nominated voice actor
boats of the Tune Squad co-founder of
retro kid we have Mr Eric bells in the
building wow the tiger sound effect and
everything that only means I lost five
times at the Emmys right that's like you
know I don't want to bring it up
like that it seems so pessimistic but
you're right that's it that's the
Canadian in me you know staying humble
and going hey you know what it was nice
just to work and leave the house and um
for that recognition I'm always just
like wow I can't believe I've lost five
times dude is it like a single person is
like a rival or arch nemesis yeah who
the [ __ ] beating you with these boys I
don't know there's just uh I've had uh
close friends it's Liam Neeson it's Liam
Neeson it's [ __ ] Oprah Mark Hamill
dude Mark I did lose tomorrow camel once
that is that's true who does he play did
you lose to Rob Paulson I have I've I
mean you can't win Dante as well Dante
uh I I had one session with him uh uh it
was a avatar the Last uh air band yeah
yeah and I was beat you at Zuko he he
just beat me as Dante he just woke up
and already lost he's he's the Filipino
that gets you know the most Eugene
Cordero is another one you know Eugene
too I've known Eugene I I've I've met
him like uh like maybe a handful of
times he was our improv teacher no way
yeah UCB he's the he's the guy now man
he's he's up there so you're mainly
known for the voice of Bugs Bunny at
Karen
Bugs Bunny yeah any carrot Donuts you
got there I noticed she got Mochi but uh
perhaps these are the designers brought
to you by yeah
[Music]
my childhoods I gotta do this
find out you could do that [ __ ] I mean
if you look at my physical state you'll
know that I watch lots of Television I
don't go out uh I just watch I used to
watch like a lot of cartoon Saturday
mornings when when we were growing up
when you could only get cartoons after
school or Saturday mornings is when I
was really studying
um Looney Tunes I mean you're like
studying that's like wow that's weird
that I'd say that and not say watching
but um you know I would I would pause
the the I would record it and I would
pause it and I would draw from it like I
would I actually if you have a pen and
paper I can actually draw animations
yeah yeah Sharpie like whatever whatever
you need we're in an office uh building
it only looks like an office
IRS paper
we might want to keep it this is a piece
of [ __ ] this is a piece of [ __ ]
we got a market
we're putting this on the [ __ ] wall
by the way that was a David Letterman
toss that was like you put it exactly
where he got it I'm gonna get an enemy
for it I wish that I hope the camera
tracked that okay so here I'll draw a
little something for you um uh I haven't
I haven't I haven't actually drawn in a
while but I used to record these
cartoons somebody get a phone no don't
do that
use this okay
I started with the nose in the mouth and
we're gonna go with the with the T this
is history man this is portrait mode are
we okay yeah I think I think the editors
will figure it out
but yeah I mean you're coming to life I
used to draw these characters all the
time well you got to use his voice as
your drama well doc you got to make sure
that cute and um the three types of hair
and the the back of the skull the other
side of the cheek he's got six whiskers
doc wow and then I always I never leave
room for my big floppy ears right here I
don't wanna I don't want to draw on your
on your fancy marble table you could do
anything you want
that's pretty much bugs stuck wow ain't
he a stinking so yeah I mean holy [ __ ]
box me it's a rough uh assimilation of
that looks like the one on the cartoons
though this is this is this is pretty
much it so um
let's go guys uh and then I shipped this
to my cousins in the Philippines and
they animate keep over here
when they're not making shoes they will
animate this overseas um can you sign it
please please sign up okay I will now
you can get
we're gonna keep we're going to frame
colors my mom will buy this off eBay
this is amazing frame this and keep it
here but yeah
all right yeah yeah I'll just
draw one yeah sure
but that's how I got into it by by
studying Round of Applause
wow too much too much but um but when do
the voice I got a question because like
um we're like we probably are the same
age
um 83.
right there 83 years old yeah 83 years
old we're right there okay
how did you invent Bugs Bunny
if we were watching Bugs Bunny at our
when we were kids well here's the thing
I I did not I I will never take any
credit for the creation of these
characters especially the the I call
them the personality these not just the
voices it's uh Mel Blanc he was the very
first actor to you know he was in in
Hollywood in Burbank in the 40s if you
could imagine like he was probably uh
smoking unfiltered cigarettes wearing
like three-piece wool suits sexy as [ __ ]
right what a monocle or something yeah
burning garbage in his back telling
people you'll never work in the city
again like that that was kind of guys
that's actually what they were telling
him oh like they had a guy at Warner's
as The Story Goes that did all the
voices for them and if you can imagine
like you know people have cameras in
their own podcast now they're making
their own shows their own content he was
still going from like CBS to NBC to ABC
like going to those three Studios and
Warner Brothers in Disney trying to get
Voice work and they just kept telling
him we have a guy sorry we have a
girlfriend we only have one guy that's
it that's all they needed back then but
until and he says that you know I kept
going to Warner Brothers knocking on the
door and uh one day they they opened it
and said uh well uh the guy died so he
got the job now so uh so then uh he he
went in there and they showed him a
picture of like all these characters
like uh Like Bugs Bunny they pitched it
as a tough little stinker you know and
and in in his pitch for the characters
like uh where is the toughest place in
America right now and it was either the
Brooklyn or the Bronx so I put the two
of them together and came up with Bugs
Bunny duck and I just thinking yeah and
then um you know it's real uh you know I
can take you through all those voices
like uh yes uh Daffy is actually not a
lot of people know and it's almost like
Eric Cartman when Trey Parker does yeah
Cartman on South Park he's not really
when I do Daffy I am doing the what we
know is Kathy and how we hear it how we
remember it
um but when he performed it he was uh
performing it as uh philvester the cat
like that is the same voice but Fed Up
it sounds like this oh [ __ ]
that's cool think about Tweety Bird um
Tweety Bird one of my favorites only a
two and a half years old and that voice
is also kind of sped up but if you kind
of drop the uh the baby voice and add
that uh Brooklyn and Bronx accent it
becomes bugs so I always I call it the
uh the house of Mel Blanc and they all
live like some of them live in the Attic
some of them live on the first floor
those are slight adjustments though tiny
tweaks yeah realize that like a Pepe Le
Pew of course really not very used these
days for obvious reservances
a little grabby but uh
TMZ trying to calling me but um if you
lose the French accent and suddenly you
start talking like it from the south
that's far I say Fog Horn Leg I pay
attention son uh yeah uh that popcorn
yeah that's it's just the difference
that uh that he puts into these
characters is amazing and again they're
over 80 years old now most of them he
did all of those characters by himself
pretty much yeah yeah I think the only
main Looney Tune that he didn't really
do was uh Elmer Fudd and that was a
another guy
oh be very very quiet I'm hunting rabbit
again a lot of time on my hands Okay so
from him how did it transition to you
well again I he died
well he did unfortunately in 1989 Mel
Blanc passed away uh and that was like I
think maybe the first 40 Years of that
character like that he took care of and
then there's still another 30 to 40
years where other people were supplying
the voice of Bugs and the rest of the
characters and you know I always have to
include people like Jeff Bergman uh Bob
Bergen uh if you don't have a Berg in
your last name then you're not working
on these characters it's bowserberg is
actually my full name but yeah no um uh
Jeff Bennett uh we got candy Milo Fred
tattershow there's so many people that
have supplied the characters for these
uh uh the voices for these characters I
should say and every single time they
Supply the voices for all of them at the
same time they were like the one person
that did I'd say Jeff Bergman was the
one that did most of the characters in
in like you know in a short or like
pretty much in in his uh resume uh in
fact it's kind of crazy to think that
only in Space Jam a new Legacy with
LeBron is the first time he's ever
voiced bugs in a future film even though
he's been doing it for 40 years so it
really is up to the people in charge
telling the story who does the voices
for these characters in the in the voice
acting world can you like hear the
difference of who did oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah for sure but what what is it what
is common to me though is the love that
they had for this character like you
could anytime I hear Jeff or or Billy
West is another guy he was uh he's
pretty much all the voices on Futurama
and he was on the Stern Show he was Ren
and Stimpy on Nickelodeon but he was
like bugs he's done you know Porky he's
done but it's it's funny I I I hear them
all and I hear how different they are
another one's Joe Laskey another one
rest in peace
um they all have you know a a Cadence
and a different pitch and tone but they
all they have that like oh yeah this is
this is what reminds me of of bugs and
it you just automatically kind of at
least for me I I I'm always invested in
and I applaud whoever's it's not an easy
job because you just said that this
other dude was doing like the Looney
Tune I mean the Space Jam LeBron version
so which version of like bugs and stuff
do you do so I'm doing uh right now I'm
on uh Looney Tunes cartoons which is a
very very much like a throwback to like
the early days because we've seen as we
grew up on top stuff yeah yeah yeah you
know including the one violence the ones
with violence the ones with the racism
the ones with them my favorite yeah yeah
yeah you know the ones where like hey
that's drawn very close to you know or
serious very different way that would
not make it to air I missed that kind of
you know what Mr is there's grit to
those cartoons and and I mean obviously
it's like there's stuff that is you know
you you can't do that you can't do that
that's wrong like that Ren and Stimpy
clip that Nick showed us oh that was
wild oh no what happened on that well
they were please
saw on this piece of wood out of his ass
see that you know again like I I was
involved in in that show before before I
became a voiceover artist you're you're
asking like how I got involved and you
know a lot of it was through drawing I
was actually a cartoonist first and I'm
sure there's like probably a lot of
animators out there and if you think
about it like Mike Judge is another one
who's an animator that does the voice uh
of Beavis and Butthead and Seth
MacFarlane another guy that was an
animator he worked on Johnny Bravo
before he you know from Hannah Barbera
him and Butch Hartman who created Fairly
OddParents they both worked at these
Animation Studios before they became
like these giant stars
um but yeah uh I was in in cartoons
first like as as an artist and the
studios that I worked at they have this
thing in animation called scratch
dialogue where it's like they can't
afford to get the big celebs or the real
voice actors so they'll pick anyone in
the studio like who clearly has problems
with not you know with chatting up and
doing his work they're like hey you you
know we we know you like doing voices
and making fun of people uh would you
like to do temporary voices for this
cartoon and that's awesome eventually
one of those cartoons got picked up and
eventually they tried not to use me and
they're like damn it he's the only one
that can do this voice so they hired why
did they try not to use you well because
you know I wasn't I wasn't in the union
yet I was and it was Nickelodeon it was
a show called El Tigre The Adventures of
Manny Rivera uh oh I heard of that
created by Jorge Gutierrez he's the one
that did Book of Life
um uh Maya and the three that was just
on Netflix
um from Tijuana he and his wife Sandra
they they gave me a shot and I you know
aside from being able to do these wacky
voices it really I owe my career to
those people you know because that
opened the door for you oh my God it
became Union and all that stuff happened
like and Nickelodeon like I'm still on
that same work visa if nothing gets me
through customs at the border faster
than doing these voices I could be
smuggling like a box of heroin and they
wouldn't care because I'd be like
you're being very entertained right get
in here yeah yeah yeah yeah I don't I
don't you're an American classic
I don't smuggle heroin just cocaine cut
that editor please
but yeah that's that's basically how I
got in and it just uh I I call it the uh
El Tigre really was the the snowflake
that started the Avalanche it was like
man oh man like whatever you ever met a
guy where his brain exploded and he was
like telling me a goddamn cheek does my
America cartoons you know what like I'm
I'm sure it's out there you know like
like look you know we went through two
different very different presidents
right one after another you know one one
really brought hope to uh this this
country and then and then the other one
was like the light that you turn on and
you still see that there's there's
roaches everywhere hiding in the shadows
you know these Canadians they come from
Canada and uh they steal all the Voice
work you know we gotta get rid of them
we gotta build a wall around Canada they
come in they take all the jobs you know
uh uh you know I have an anchor baby
according to him my son was born in
burping so I'm trying I'm trying to hold
on to being a Canadian Professor that
kept talking about how he was an illegal
immigrant
it's crazy you know what's funny is
um this is my prediction about the
future with entertainment all of these
legendary from bands to voices and
everything all of them are going to be
taken over by Filipinos really because
we have it started with journey now Bugs
Bunny
I'm trying to try to try to make those
connections there yeah I don't know what
it is about uh Filipinos on destined to
be entertainers yeah and then they can
do the voices really well they're just
born with those jeans so anything yeah
so all of our I'm just glad you grew up
watching cartoons instead of like
Baywatch yeah I do the perfect Castle we
can't use you I don't know
how
a voice so
an insanely phenomenal ability in these
[ __ ] cartoons that we grew up you're
already blowing my mind and obviously
you have a very very good Trump what
other uh accents Impressions the one
when they were asking you to do like the
doc the animal documentary thing and
then you started sounding like the
narrator like David Attenborough oh
Edinburgh yeah yeah you got it girl well
I had to drive all the way here from
Sherman Oaks the Wilds of Sherman Oaks
and deal with 101 traffic very bad
around the downtown area to see the
local angelinos in mating season on the
side of the room how is that coming out
of it that's great I don't know I don't
know what it is about that voice but uh
there's just that sounds like your real
voice and now you're [ __ ] around yeah
this is this is fake why are you [ __ ]
around right now man we're here in
Monterey Park
known for its Boba
you cannot drive five feet in this area
without seeing a boba side yeah I don't
know very good it's very it's fair oh
thanks guys
insane with these voices right what
what's the licensing and like all the
legal things like like are you allowed
to use it for like Cameo or dual Cameo
honest it's just our voicemail box it is
it's a very valid question I mean even
at conventions you know like there are
some artists that straight up use the
artwork that is you know for autographs
and stuff that is is fine it's like
you know they've been doing it they've
been doing voices for like decades and
of course they're going to want to meet
the fans and reach out to the fan like
Comic-Con is huge New York Comic-Con is
coming up San Diego just passed and in
between those big ones there's so many
like smaller ones I've seen people uh
use actual artwork I've seen uh people
use art commissioned by someone else so
it's not a direct yeah copy of like
trademarked art but I think most big
corporations like werners or Disney or
Nick
um DreamWorks now you know they kind of
turn to Blind Eye I think and go
whatever you know like that's nice I
have like uh some [ __ ] high level
crazy Insurance on your voice or some
sort of like copy yeah
Celine Dion by any means I don't
apparently she's bigger dude
[Laughter]
draw me like one of your French coils
yeah
Titanic Celine Dion everything My Heart
Will Go On yeah Bugs Bunny covers the
hits um yeah I I you know I heard that
she doesn't speak the entire day on
Sunday that vocal rest is some something
that I think no matter what you do if
you drink all the tea in the world and
keep uh hydrated you know vocal rest you
gotta do that too
you know there was only one time in the
last like five years and it was after
San Diego Comic-Con where I came back
and no symptoms no no it was a complete
surprise and I had pressed the next day
all day I couldn't talk and it was like
the most embarrassing there's no voice
yeah and I I felt fine all day on Sunday
and then I wake up Monday and I was like
I sounded like a like a a Funkhouser on
Curb Your Enthusiasm you know Super Dave
Osborne he's
he kind of has that rough voice he has
that rough kind of and then everyone's
like this guy's Bugs Bunny like oh yeah
it was the probably the worst time for
anyone to ask me to do voices because I
couldn't do it do you have your vocal
cords insured I do not I do not I I have
uh and you know ear throat nose
specialist ENT uh that every time if I
am in a situation where I can't talk
they'll you know they'll give me the the
steroid the vitamins Oh They'll do like
a vapor
um antibiotics and then assign me to
vocal rest but it's usually like within
like three days Dr Warren line in
Burbank if you're ever and he handles
like all the you know voice performers
singers boy band he'll tell me all like
the people that come through that gate
and yeah I mean like you know look at
someone like the weekend who who just
had to cancel the show like halfway
through or like even four songs in and
he's like I can't sing I can't like I
lost I'm so sorry sorry like you know
like maybe he shouldn't have talked so
much
ask questions or they have to rehearse
they should maybe type more
do you just because we're here and
absolute fans as well and there seems to
be like no cap on that Sharpie and a
blank page yeah anybody else that you
love drawings oh man that we can keep at
the office well this is uh of all the
Looney Tunes characters I think um okay
here we go uh I'd say the I've only been
voicing uh ant bugs Daffy and Tweety for
like the last four years uh the last 12
to 15 years I've been voicing uh Marvin
the Martian
um he he was the guy that was in in one
of the original uh Jordan commercials uh
with bugs that kind of started Space Jam
but yeah uh I I really do enjoy your
show but it blocks my view of Venus
um
dude it's also the things he chooses to
say that are gems it's not just that he
sounds like them that's the hard part
about Impressions right is is is not
just sounding like him but like actually
you're gonna be him like actually like
how they talk what they would say what
they might say he's got a little oblong
uh shaped helmet today but uh in in
short notice that that'll do earth
creature yeah you got my good side yeah
yeah Marvin Marvin Marvin has has been
like my favorite since the beginning and
to be honest he was actually
uh in the original Stretch uh the least
amount of like they're in 40 years I
think he only had like five cartoons or
something like that but a lot of kids
love Marvin he's so cool I have all I
have a piece of Marvin that I made when
I was like
six really yeah and I kept it wow I'll
show you in a minute you gotta show you
gotta show the goods
foreign